um
uh dr karstens is the mentor of both of
them i'm going to let her be the mc
and that way i can turn off my camera
and eat my lunch but i will be listening
and look forward to the talks so it's
all yours lisa
thank you i'm very excited to uh have
lily and palmer two interns that were uh
working with me over the summer
um tell you a little bit about their
projects um you'll see their projects
are quite different from each other and
that's based on uh their primary
interests and um also the needs of the
research that goes on in my lab which
primarily uses a lot of data science and
bioinformatics to try to understand
bacteria
in the bladder and how it relates to
women's health
um with that i'll let lilly say a brief
intro about herself and she will tell
you about
um some of the metadata um
work that she's been focusing on this
summer
hi everyone i'm lily and i'm an
undergraduate at the university of
southern california
i'll go ahead and share my screen
all right
so my presentation is going to be on the
challenges and solutions for microbiome
metadata cleaning and clinical research
for an outline of our presentation i'll
talk a little bit about overactive
bladder or oab
since the metadata that i worked with
was collected as part of the oeb study
i'll go over what metadata is and the
importance of metadata
then walk through a sample metadata
quitting process and talk about some
takeaways and future steps
so overactive water syndrome is
characterized by symptoms of urinary
urgency urinary frequency nighttime
voiding and urgency urinary incontinence
which is having a strong urge followed
by immediate leakage of a large volume
of urine
it affects around 19 percent of women
over the age of 44.
and the diaphragm to the right
shows a basic illustration of what
occurs with this disorder but the
pathophysiology is not fully understood
so recent studies have found that
overactive bladder may be connected to
interactions of bacteria in the bladder
so this overactive flatter study aims to
identify what kinds of bacteria are
found in the bladder and if there are
any associations with symptoms of
overactive water
the basic procedure involved collecting
some urine samples via a catheter system
then they sequence the 16s rna genes
from these samples and the 16s rrna gene
is frequently used in urinary microbiome
studies
then after a lot of processing steps
they were able to identify
what bacteria
are identified by these gene sequences
and with that information you can do
analyses like these where you compare
the relative abundance of different
types of bacteria in each of your
samples
so in addition to collecting the gene
sequencing data you also want to collect
metadata
and this is data that describes and
gives information about other data
it's really important in sequencing
projects because large volumes of
sequencing data require context such as
where the sequences come from how are
they processed how are they produced in
order to understand and then analyze
them
particularly with microbiome research
metadata is important since
the cyber research aims to identify the
interactions between the host and the
microbiome so having information about
the host is really important
to provide that context
and lastly metadata helps to increase
the reproducibility and facilitates data
sharing and reuse of your work since the
goseen data is often banks and
repositories so that they can be
accessed by other researchers or
yourself in the future
there are a few different types of
metadata
what i'm focusing on today is going to
be sample metadata so in human subjects
research that would be information about
the hosts such as their age their gender
what medications they're on what
pre-existing health conditions they may
have
there's also information about the
sample itself so what type of sample is
it is it a blood or a urine sample and
then other forms of metadata are
preparation data processing and feature
metadata because there are a lot of
different methods that can be used for
processing your data sequences or
different databases that you can use to
identify what bacteria those sequences
align with
so having that information provided is
also really important
so for the oab study the clinical
metadata that was collected included a
three-day bladder diary
and this is an example of what an entry
of one of those
diary phase would look like so you would
have your fluid intake what type of
fluid if you had any leaks or accidents
if you urinated in the toilet your
urgency severity and any activities that
you were doing when you leaked or had an
urge
other clinical metadata included
information about the study visit such
as the amount of urine that was
collected
there's also information about the
sample so that could be the results of a
year analysis like shown on the right
we also collected the subject's medical
and social history
that would include their pre-existing
health conditions and other
information about their medications and
treatments
and in addition there were some
questionnaires about their quality of
life their stress and anxiety and these
all helped to evaluate the severity of
their overactive bladder symptoms
so there are a couple issues that are
associated with collecting clinical
metadata the first is that it can be
prone to entry errors since everything
is manually entered by research
personnel and the second is that it can
be disorganized or non-informative when
it is first entered
to resolve these issues would require
some data verification and cleaning
processes
in order to make the data more analysis
friendly or tidy
so here we have an example of data that
is untidy this is what you might get
when you initially enter the data in
and after you want to process this data
to look something more like this which
would be a lot more analysis friendly so
the basic guidelines for making tidy
data is having one observation per row
one variable per column and then one
measurement per the cell looking more
specifically at the changes between
these two
tables
we can look at the species column first
so
we had either homo sapiens or human were
entered for the species column in this
data table
but we want
the same
meaning to have the same data value so
we change both of them to homo sapiens
for the date column there are a lot of
different formats for dates
so we change that to this which is a
standard format
so that it can be all the same in the
cleaning cleaner version of the table
in the group column we have some
differences with either capitalization
or abbreviations
so similarly to the other two columns we
made that to be
a same value for the same meaning
next is the location column and you can
see the column name for this one was
capitalized while all the others were
not
so you also want your column names to
have the same
format so we had that be lowercase
and then for the values this one was in
city state format and this one was
for oshsu so we also changed that to
both these in city state format
the last column you can see in the
untidy version there are two values in
one column so you'll want to split that
up so they have their own columns
and then i also moved the units into
the column name so that the values are
just a numeric value which will make it
much easier if you want to do any
calculations
and for the units we also change them so
that they would match since originally
the units were different
for the two rows
that's for helping to kind of tidy up
the data
and
then the process for resolving entry
errors would involve first performing a
double data entry so that would mean
having two different research personnel
both enter the data into a data set that
you have two data sets
you would then identify any differences
between the two data sets
so that you can verify and resolve those
differences and that will help to
minimize any entry errors
so the step that i focused on
was the second one of identifying the
differences between the two data sets
i used a couple r packages to help with
this the first is compare df it was
downloaded from github and created by
alexand joseph
this contains a single function compare
underscore df that will create the
comparison objects from two data frames
the second package that works in
conjunction with this one is html table
and it will create a table that
highlights the differences between the
two datasets
so prior to comparing the two data sets
and using the um our packages i did some
processing of the raw data so this is an
example of
raw water diary data
and the first thing i did was help
improve human readability so i added
labels to all the column names
so that it's the data is more
understandable and easier to work with
then you want to ensure that the rows
and the columns match between the two
entered data sets so that you can do the
comparison
so this is a subset of the initial entry
and this is a subset of the second entry
so here we have
five variables shown and then it's for
three different subjects
so looking at these two there were two
main differences the first was that all
the column names in the second entry had
an extra underscore two
and this is because when we do the
double data entry and red cap it
requires different variable names for
each value so we had to make the
variable names for the second entry to
be different from the first but when
we're doing this comparison we want them
to be the same so
in r i was able to remove these extra
underscore 2 from the second entry
column names
the second
issue was that a few of the columns
differed in their ordering
so
this is for the day three data and what
i did was i looked at days one and two
and the order of the accuracy notes and
average intake columns matched the
initial entry
in this order while the second entry was
different
so i took the second data set and i
reordered those three columns that they
would all match
and after that was done now we have the
two data sets where the rows and the
columns all match in their order and
their names
so then we can proceed to creating the
comparison table
so first we have that compare df
function here
the first argument is going to be the
initial entry data set
the second will be the second entry data
set
this value will be the variable that you
want to group the columns by so i wanted
to group them by the record id
and the last one is
where you can put any columns that you
want to exclude so we wanted to exclude
the notes column
for the example that was shown and
that's the freehand column and it's
going to be different between the data
sets
then you can run the create output table
function on this creative comparison
object
and you will end up with something that
looks like this
so on the left here would be the record
ids
and then these two rows would be for one
record id where the top or the green
row would be what is entered in the
initial entry
and the bottom would be for the second
entry
and then any of the values that are
colored green are going to be unique to
the first entry and if it's colored red
it's going to be unique to the second
entry so this just helps to highlight
the differences between the two
and then from this table you want to
determine which differences actually
require verification
so this is going to be different based
on what data you're working with
but with the bladder diary data the
average values are the most important to
have matched between the two because
those are the values that are actually
going to be looked at in downstream
analysis
so
for example
in the first two rows
there's one average column here and the
average is
four different between the two recording
uh two entered data sets
so those might be
record ideas that you would want to go
back and verify
but the third one
there was one difference in this column
here but the average value and other
average values that aren't shown in this
slide all match between the two data
sets so this wouldn't be a record id
that you would have to go back and
verify
so after identifying which ones require
verification you would then go and
actually review
those record ids
then we are working on resolving those
identified errors and
i did the both the water diary and study
visit information data sets
and then after resolving those you want
to repeat the process just to make sure
that everything that needs to be
resolved has been resolved
and doing this in r is very convenient
because then you already have the
scripts written and you can run just
from the data sets through that same
script
then once everything has been verified
and cleaned you can proceed to your
analysis
and that covers the project that i did
with the metadata cleaning
some other takeaways from this
internship have been learning how to use
lys r for data cleaning
i've
learned about the departments of
documentation
all my work has been done in r and r
markdown files where you can write both
your code and then also plain text to
explain what you're doing and why you're
doing it
i've also learned about how the
collection of metadata plays an
important role in microbiome research
and there's a lot of work being done
right now in the questions lab and other
labs and organizations to create
metadata standards
so that all researchers can
collect and report the necessary
metadata with their
research and that can be more
reproducible and reusable
and lastly that studying the urinary
microbiome poses many unique challenges
since the urinary microbiome is a
relatively new field
and there are a lot of questions so
about what are the best methods to use
and issues that are yet to be resolved
that palmer will also talk about in her
presentation
and lastly just some acknowledgements um
thank you to my mentors dr carsons and
dr gourding
the national institute of diabetes and
digestive and kidney diseases who helped
to fund the study and of course the ohsu
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology for this
internship experience and thank you all
for listening
thanks can we can we ask some questions
yeah
great um very very nice talk and um you
um exemplify actually a problem that we
know is very challenging in our field
which is how we go from
data that's collected in the real world
often for other purposes
and then we want to do research with it
and we run into these problems that the
data is not standardized it's in
different formats um before you actually
got to the last slide about the next
steps i would i was going to ask but but
i think maybe it's still a pertinent
question um you know how how confident
were you that
you know for example when you had um
height and weight in the same cell that
that you
parsed out those numbers properly
so that um once you got into a more tidy
data form that you could feel confident
that
the underlying
you know all the transformations you had
done were correct
yeah
so
for the example that was just like an
example data set that i made for the
presentation but it wasn't with the
actual data but for just cleaning the
data in general
um
i guess just making running it multiple
times or
going over and checking every time
before you keep going
or also since we had the two different
data sets to run it on both and then be
able to compare and make sure both were
cleaned and tidy
okay i mean the the um
the the the takeaway point you know is
that um
we oftentimes have challenges with um
you know data sets that we reuse for
other purposes not not that we shouldn't
do it um but um you know there's we
always need to kind of keep in mind you
know where the data came from and
how it might need to be cleaned thanks
are there any other questions questions
really
if not um we can move on to palmer who
is going to
discuss some of the work that she's been
doing over the summer with quantitative
microbiome profiling so more focusing on
the sequencing side of data and um
trying to improve the information we can
get out of it
all right can you guys hear me okay
hopefully okay great let me get my
presentation going
all right
all right like lisa said um my name is
palmer and i'm a senior undergraduate
majoring in math and biology at lewis
and clark college here in portland
and um i was also in the carson's lab
with lily
but i was working on
in the quantitative microbiome profiling
project working on detecting bias
um but before we get into that i thought
it would be beneficial to just talk a
little bit about the human microbiome
and bacteria so
bacteria viruses and archaea live all
over our bodies and most of the time
they help our bodies function properly
exchanging materials and helping our
systems
but when a microbiome is diversity is
skewed or there's an abnormally large
presence of one type of bacteria
things can sort of start to go wrong
and so
um
the microbiomes in our body have
different levels of diversity so for
example
our urinary microbiome has
a relatively low
microbial biomass whereas the gut is
considered to be high
um
microbial biomass and so um there are
two ways that we can look at and study
these microbes
the first is
culture based and the second which we'll
be focusing on is culture independent
and so this involves metagenomic or
shotgun sequencing which aims to
sequence all of the microbial dna in a
sample and the other type is marker gene
sequencing
and so we're going to focus on markogen
sequencing because it's the method that
was used in this project
and so markogen sequencing works to just
sequence a specific region of the
microbes dna to determine what type of
bacteria it is
and so this is often done using the 16s
rrna gene that is specific to bacteria
um so this gene consists of
multiple hypervariable regions in this
picture you can kind of see them
um
that
you can essentially search for to
determine what type of bacteria it is
and so it's kind of you can think of it
as like
we use fingerprints to identify people
um we can look at a
16sr rna gene as a bacteria's
fingerprint um to help us figure out
what type of bacteria it is and so this
method has been verified by the human
microbiome project as well as the earth
microbiome project
and so um
yeah marker gene sequencing takes
biological material and works to output
the corresponding bacterial profile
of that microbiome so it increases our
ability to measure biological
communities and for example to
understand diseases that occur in the
gut the bladder the vagina these are all
places where we have microbiomes and so
like in this picture
you essentially take a sample of
bacteria and in this sample we have
three purple bacteria two orange and one
teal
and we put them through the sequencing
and we get out um
how many of them there are or they're
relative abundance in most cases um but
like in this picture you'll see that
it misrecorded it said there were four
orange ones
one purple and three teal
um bacterial profiles that go through
sequencing are are often biased so that
means that some bacteria are more easily
detected than others
which is why it picked up the orange one
more than
the purple one even though the purple
had higher abundance
and so my portion of this project
focused on
a recently developed mathematical model
for estimating this bias
and applying it to um the mock microbial
dilution series which i'll talk about in
a little bit um and so mclaren willis
and callahan
are the authors that proposed
and wrote this model and so it looks at
how bias distorts bacterial compositions
measured by marker gene and
metadomic sequencing
and so this model is represented in a
package in r which is a statistical
competing languages language um
called medical and so um r has lots of
different packages that can help us um
make plots and do all sorts of things
but this package works specifically on
detecting bias
and so
excuse me um like i said this package
works on getting quantitative bias
estimations
and then
using those bias estimations to
calibrate our observed abundances so
that they are closer to the actual
abundances
and so
for example let's say you sequenced a
microbiome and
this was your sort of like
this is your data um
and so
this staircase that's sort of like
behind the points is what you know is
actually in your sample
um but when you put your sample through
sequencing
this is what it recorded like the points
in color are what um
it said the abundance of each bacteria
was
um
and so
the medical package takes that and it
makes it
more like this so these
each of these points are now much more
accurate and precise toward to the
actual composition of the sample
and so um
we know how much bias
is impacting
each bacteria within the sample
and so um i'm going to shift lenses here
a bit and talk about um the project in
the carson's lab that i was a part of
and discuss how all this is tied
together afterwards um
so one of the projects that the carson's
lab is working on right now is
quantitative microbiome profiling which
means um obtaining the counts or
absolute abundances of the microbes in a
sample
and so specifically the carson lab works
on microbiomes that have low microbial
biomass um like i mentioned earlier and
so my project driven in this was to look
at how bias impacts these low microbial
biomass samples
and in order to see how bias impacts
microbiomes of varying biomass
the carson's lab and capability created
a mock microbial dilution series
and so there are nine levels in this
mock microbial dilution series
starting at
undiluted
which is pretty much full concentration
so that could represent like our gut
which has a relatively high
um
biomass whereas um
these lower or more diluted samples
um could represent like the urinary
microbiome that is lower microbial
biomass
and so an important thing to note is
that the the microbial series has eight
different bacteria in it and they are
all
of equal proportions that's those are
the actual abundances they're one to one
um
and so um
this is what
the dilution series looks like um when
we plot it
as we go along
towards the more diluted samples we get
um more contaminants and
obviously the
data or the abundances change um
and so
another part of
the quantitative microbiome profiling
project is
investing the role that contaminants
play in high versus low microbial
biomass samples
and so um
it was sort of interesting to see how
my project was impacted by these
contaminants
and so just to sort of sum up this intro
part um
the question that i aimed to focus on
for my project was how well does the
medical approach assess bias on samples
of varying biomass
and the microbial dilution series so
we're putting together this
bias calibration aspect and
this dilution series
and so the first step that the medi-cal
package proposed was to sort of figure
out what what does our data look like
what is in these samples and so what i
did to do this
or to get a feel for it i guess was um
to create this tile plot and so
the bacteria are on the y-axis
while the dilution sample is on the
x-axis on the bottom now and so
d0 this is our undiluted sample
um and then d8 is our most diluted
sample
and so the tiles are colored
corresponding to their relative
abundance and so dark blue tiles
represent um
high abundance whereas this yellow
represents
low abundance um and so because the mock
microbial dilation series is one to one
for all eight bacteria
if we had a flawless sequencing um event
in which
there wasn't any bias then we would
expect to see all of these
sort of the same color sort of this like
mid
bluish green um
but
our sequencing picked up these bacteria
more than it picked up these bacteria
and so there is some bias appetite
and the other thing to note is that the
top row um
is this other type of bacteria and so
this represents all of the bacteria that
we observed
that were not
the eight known bacteria in the sample
so in other words these are our
contaminants um and so
i think it's interesting to notice that
like as you progress down the dilution
series um
the abundance of this other or
contaminants um
category increases and that is sort of
what we would expect because low
microbial biomass
um
samples typically have more contaminants
just because there's less stuff in them
to begin with
and so um that's just something to point
out um with this tile plot
um i also created a box plot to show
the quantitative microbial biomass data
abundance and variability just a bit
differently
and so you can see sort of the same
trends we have um
these were absorbed observed at a higher
abundance than they actually are present
um and then we have
those that are observed at a lower
abundance um
and then this other category has some
variability in it
and so um
using the medical package the next step
that i took was looking at the dilution
series and visually assessing how much
bias there was
with the tile plot and the box plot we
know that there is some bias in play but
we don't really know how much and so to
do this i plotted the observed
abundances on the y-axis
and the actual abundances on the x-axis
and so
um and then the they're colored by the
dilution series and so this gray line
is um
what
is where the sample should lie if there
isn't any bias so that that's like our
perfect um
sample
abundance right there and then um the
other thing to note is that
these points do appear in sort of a
column because the actual abundances are
equal for all bacteria because it's one
to one for every sample
um
but you can see how some
um
some bacteria are observed at a
or some dilution series the samples in
dilution series have higher than actual
abundance observed for the bacteria in
them and some have lower
um and so this gives us sort of a feel
for how much bias
um and then another way that i thought
to look at this was maybe if we look at
each bacteria we can have a better sense
because the overall graph shows that
there is bias but not
per bacteria and so each of these
squares is a different bacteria um
that is present in the mock microbial
dilution series the eight recorded
bacteria
and then the colors vary based off of
which dilution series they're a part of
like in the last plot
and so for example
if we look at lactobacillus we see that
throughout the dilution series
um
lactobacillus was observed at a higher
abundance than what was actually present
in every sample
but with staphylococcus we
all of the
dilution series samples are
observed lower than what was actually
there and so the yellow dot in the
middle of these plots
is um
the unbiased or expected observation so
that's what we would want to see if
there was no bias in play and so
um
it definitely does pick up so far the
medical package on um
how much bias is in play with each
bacteria
and so um the next step was to sort of
we know there's bias we know which
bacteria are experiencing bias um
how much
what is our quantitative
bias estimation and so medi-cal has a
function for this it's called estimate
bias um
and so you put in the um
actual known abundances of your bacteria
and the observed abundances
and it outputs the bias and so um we can
kind of see the same trends here
these top three are um the ones that
were observed in like the dark blue and
the tile plot um so those are observed
at a higher than um actual abundance and
um then it just declines from then on
and so the table is helpful for analysis
and we can use these estimates later
but i think it is actually more helpful
to see these plotted
and so um this is just the same data and
you can kind of see
which ones have more bias and which ones
have
less bias but still some bias in play um
and this gray line up the middle is
the like perfect um no bias um
line here and so
um
yeah so it's just i think it's kind of
interesting to look at and now we know
how much bias is in play for each
um bacteria
and so
the next step going forward would be to
um
sort of calibrate our observed
abundances so
using our bias estimations medi-cal has
a feature where or a function where
it inputs the observed and the bias and
then it outputs the calibrated amount so
it essentially
um
adjusts for the bias that is present
and so
here so this i didn't get to this my
computer crashed yesterday it was very
damaging
to my progress on this project but um
going forward it would be useful to do
this and so this bacteria is um
or i guess their fungus it's from the
tutorial for the medi-cal
project
and so
these were there observed and then these
are their actual and so
this calibrated is
using the observed and the biases
and you can see how much closer the
proportions of the bacteria are to the
actual after we've calibrated
and um so i also want to talk a little
bit about limitations and so
one of the main things that we found
to be limiting with this package is that
um
in some instances you can't develop a
control sample that covers the range of
bacteria present in the community that
you're drawing samples from
and so the authors of the package and
the paper mention this limitation
they say it might be useful to do
partial calibration when abundances are
known for like a key bacteria that's in
the community
um but they don't provide an example and
there aren't a ton of functions for that
within the package
and so um with the quantitative
microbiome profiling data
we knew
that all the samples were one to one we
knew the abundances relative
of each bacteria
but um if we were to pull a sample from
a human subject we're not going to know
exactly what bacteria is there we could
know maybe one or two that we could
expect
but um we don't know their abundances
and so that's definitely a limitation
that maybe this isn't super applicable
to real world samples
um and the other
uh limitation that we found is that
contamination in low biomass samples
isn't super talked about
um
in this project i just lumped all of
them into this other category
um
but
they
i mean they take up a lot of these
samples at low microbial biomass um
in this dilution series and so i think
it would be really interesting to see
how contamination impacts bias and um
if there are functions for that that
would also be useful
um and then i also just wanted to touch
base on sort of my takeaways for the
internship
going into this i didn't know anything
about the microbiome i didn't know
really how to use r um which is a
programming language i didn't know
um
that bias even existed and so um i
really had a it was a really eye-opening
experience for me
and um learning about marker gene
sequencing all the implications to do
with that how to plot
images um and figures in our
is definitely something that i'm going
to use hopefully for the rest of my life
um
and
yeah the whole contaminants situation is
really problematic and
a big issue same with bias and so
learning about that was um really
interesting
and then i wanted to just um
thank the ohsu demise
department um the mentors and the staff
you guys have made this experience
really seamless from a remote
perspective
um which was awesome like i felt really
included all the time which was great
because
yeah
being remote can be really hard
sometimes and so
um i also just wanted to thank dr lisa
carstens and kate bowie who are my
mentors for this and the entire carson's
lab um helped out a lot they made it a
really great online community so it was
really enjoyable out there
and then i just have my resources
so
any questions
great i actually don't have a question
but i i actually um uh did want to
mention that um the way that palmer
learned about our program uh was through
the amia first look program aimia for
those who don't know is the american
medical informatics association which
has this program
that
focuses on
women
pursuing
graduate study and careers in
informatics and somehow even though
palmer's going to school what about
three miles or five miles away from ohsu
learned about our program through the
first look program in in normal times
they actually fund um
the the travel for um some number of um
college women who um
apply and get accepted
maybe at some point in the future and
probably not this year um the program
will go back to being in person it was
virtual last year so uh we got to meet
her that way and um i'm glad this worked
out and that she got to um learn a lot
and contribute to dr carsten's research
so i have a question palmer if i'm
allowed to ask um
so
i thought it was really interesting with
your bias estimates it looked like some
of the bacteria actually had more spread
than others do you do you know why or
like how would that be adjusted for if
you're trying to correct bias it seems
like some of them
like
you'd actually have to have a diff i
don't know if you'd be able to correct
um crack for the bias and like say
lactobacillus if you go to the the plot
that had the
um that showed where how different it
was from the expected yeah here
yeah
sales has a huge spread of like the
amount of difference where like you know
it looks like staphylococcus right it's
very like it's it's always the same
wrong answer
yeah i don't know if you have any
insight into like
why or like how would you be able to
correct for that because it kind of
seems like
yeah lactobacillus would be really hard
to accurately correct
yeah i don't know i was thinking about
this yesterday because um there is such
a big spread and it's like the d0 is
really different than the d8 um and so
it might be interesting to run
the um
the medical estimate bias function on
just
like
each sample at a time um to see if the
bias estimations change for that
um
but
i don't really i don't know if it's
taking in um
like if it's just averaging all of them
to create the bias estimate or if it's
um
weighting it somehow um
but that
yeah it's definitely interesting to
think about and
i'd have to do more research to
understand it
thank you
okay well um if we have no further
questions um i too want to thank
lily and palmer for their talks and lisa
for hosting them
over the summer and
[Music]
will adjourn at this point have a great
day everyone
you